when you spend a lot of time together
you can take each other for granted the
more you are together the more aware of
those little problems that can spring up
that uh that are under the surface that
make may become a big problem I think at
this point what we've realized is most
things don't matter save the actual
fighting and animosity and argument for
when there is actually something to
argue about petty little things we've
we're good with that back in March Terry
and Heather de bro got candid about
their marriage during a chat with E.T
and now the Real Housewives of Orange
County Star is slamming rumors that her
husband is having an affair it was crazy
it all went down after a real housewives
fan account alleged Heather was skipping
out on filming the next season of the
series due to cheating rumors swirling
online while Heather was having none of
that and slid right into the comments to
shut it down keeping it short and sweet
quote this is not true on any level
so many people ask me what is the secret
to a long lasting marriage and I will
tell you first of all it's separate
bathrooms 100 percent
gotta have some mystery
the other thing is you really have to
have a way to connect with each other
Terry and I work together is that crazy
but we like to work so we have our
skincare line we do a podcast together
we turn it into a date night the couple
tied the knot in 1999 and share four
kids together and as fans of the
franchise know putting their marriage
out there for the world to see hasn't
always been easy so why are you mad at
me what really why am I mad
okay never mind
why do you think I'm mad because I was a
butthead at dinner
yeah you really were it's very stressful
um on your marriage I think that's why
you see so many people getting divorced
in reality television that I think it
was our third season
we were fighting I mean we were just
fighting a lot and it wasn't like us and
it was the show and so it came to a head
and I said to him I go look we have a
choice this is not good for our marriage
so either I'm quitting the show and we
are done or we have to figure out how to
do this show
appropriately honestly and together and
during et's chat with the duo in March
they opened up about how they make it
work all these years later in terms of
our journey we've seen and done it all
I've lost millions of dollars okay I've
gotten to the point where I felt so bad
about myself I gained so much weight on
going through such a self-moving period
where I didn't feel you know attractive
enough to be intimate with this
beautiful woman and so we have over the
years learned how to identify our
problems how to fight well when we fight
now we say all right at least I do I
can't speak for Heather I'll have her
speak in a minute but I say don't say it
don't push that button it may be feel
good to do it don't go there Terry
because that's going to escalate this
and now we're gonna have two weeks of
misery so I've learned a lot of this
about through this show and this process
[Music]
thank you